[Musique]
oui wen
je te laisse ouais je suis en train de
faire une fausse mise en scène pour le
début de soirée na na waie salut c'est
moi d'avion salut je voulais regarder
les aventuriers du système solaire oui
je vais suivre la question s'appelle ce
plaisir
bah vous n'avez pas le choix ça se dit
j'ai choisi
aulas est un dessin animé
c'est un dessin ni s'agit d'un dessin
animé et surtout c'est déjà extrêmement
[Musique]
week
ashley c'est très proche de retard
à tout moment le film c'est juste un
générique genre gigantesque ses
deuxièmes sont bons ils commencent leur
est d'accord c'est pas des décennies
mais j'ai parlé récemment dessin animé
incroyable bonjour tout le monde
professeur pourquoi nous attaquent-ils
parce qu il a 37 ans
on disait hitchcock le maître du
suspense mais l'agrément n'est pas mal
je pense qu'à une passion pour les plans
très longtemps chez prédateurs
non mes connaissances et warner qu'un
mec qui balaye j'ai jamais vu un mec
balayant aussi effrayante avec sa
musique qui déboule 10-1 figure toujours
au plus devraient pouvoir laisse mes
sourcils froncés toujours du film rain
fuku souk où l'on a ici la sécurité du
secteur une chambre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on peut juste se souvenir que tout à
l'heure pour un mec qui balayait
dynamique la plus grande du monde et
[Applaudissements]
qu'un césar il va attraper aucun césar
et
ils saluent alors sa mort ça ne marche
pas du tout la guerre de poisson là
dedans je suis c'est mieux que rien
bah non c'est rien c'est mieux que rien
pensez vous que les communistes vont
venir
je ne sais pas il faut que je ne sais
pas d'ailleurs une apparition de
vaisseau spatial est ce que vous êtes
tous prévoient attendre et de chant même
si ça ne fait pour l'instant on est un
peu oui là on épouse dans une école de
cambolle incroyable les oubliés des
plans avec les comédiens de piste gelée
dessus est-ce qu'on est tous d'accord
aussi que les dessins de jean ces gens
au 27 ans afin que les comédiens
habitants
au volant c'est valérian et laureline à
cela dit c'est mieux que le film de
besson draps méchoui pas où est le
problème
vous êtes arrivé au shopi on peut tous
se rappeler que tous les continents et
et asiatiques
[Rires]
[Musique]
déjà que monsieur le président nous
essayons de réunifier le pays
mais cela semble difficile de nous
allier à vous dire tu es n'y aura aucun
problème la volée de coup droit là là
mais ils font des essais nucléaires sas
musée actuellement n'a pas pris une ride
mais il n'y a plus rien qui pourra nous
empêcher de gagner maintenant c'est une
urgence qu'allons nous faire
c'est une urgence médicale à 0,8 g
nous allons lui servir du métal pour
construire notre propre robot
oui monsieur même les martiens ou les
problèmes de calvitie
[Musique]
moi général vos pertes sont très
importantes comment allez vous
m'expliquer ce carnet où se trouvent les
intrigues dans mon nom vient de frapper
le mais de manière mesurée
[Musique]
[Rires]
est ce que c'est cette lumière qui
clignotait que tu aies pu mieux qui
clignotent
alors il ya deux voies il ya deux voies
se verrait devoir de tout faire
[Musique]
c'est vraiment systématique des cas de
musique on s'emmerde quoi comme il y en
a depuis le début il reste une heure de
film car la paille photo wl salonique
on l'a déjà vu sa flore adjani c'est les
mêmes plans tu veux dire que la brigade
ont été détruits oui ils ont tous été
détruits par un vent beau qu'on a pris
pour un morceau de 10 le temps de lancer
de déchets attendez c'est un morceau de
décès alors sept ans et si tout ça
n'était qu'un rêve
dans la tente je pense que je n'aurai ce
que tu as vraiment raison tu as raison
c'est sur wii 10 boulet qui crut me
garde de garde
donc c'était bien ça on met tout ça
n'était qu'un rêve
au petit déjeuner qu'un mauvais rêve et
on est d'accord qu'ils ont filmé ça
toute la journée est classée le soir ils
sont dit merde on n'a pas fait le plein
de lait de la ferme en stand by à la
main 5 4 trop le croire
[Musique]
je vais vous donner un petit peu prenons
le temps de disette anciens propose
qu'on débrief je suis un peu chamboulé
ben moi c'est fait allégorie du
communisme ni nab fait tout au long du
film on voit ça tous les pilotes dans
quel pays ça se passe de cinq jours dans
la vie même si on a bouleversé la petite
cindy qui me paraît barney vous
remarquez qu'à pas de générique général
on a eu le dessus
tu veux parler des 25 premières minutes
merci d'avoir regardé soirées nanars on
a appris après visionnage que c'était un
film de propagande sud coréenne et que
le bon les deux coups étaient en fait la
véritable d'humeur du leader de la corée
du nord de l'époque 16 pas si drôle en
fait balance nous ton nanar préféré en
commentaire allez salut à la prochaine
abonne toi vous savez
abattoir culé ta gueule jamais salanque
eu les solos
[Musique]